today a day of parliamentary theater but
for all the drama above all this a quest
for truth from a former prime minister
two o'clock came and time for Boris
Johnson to give Parliament and the
country his version of events under oath
the truthful truth and nothing but the
truth nearly four hours of questioning
trying to determine if he'd done just
that in Parliament back in December
2021. the guidance was followed in the
rules of father at all times Mr Johnson
today still Resolute I'm here to say to
you hand on heart that I did not lie to
the house when those statements were
made they were made in good faith and on
the basis of what I honestly knew and
believed at the time accepting he misled
Parliament but insisting it was a
mistake not malicious I apologize for
inadvertently misleading this house but
to say that I did it recklessly or
deliberately is completely untrue this
committee though forensic and when
pressed on dates and detail the form of
PM quickly uncomfortable
this a gathering at the height of the
pandemic and then PM raising a glass and
thanking advisors who'd left their jobs
the photographs show a lack of social
distancing of two meters which was
required by the workplace guidance at
the time
could you accept that we're present at
this Gathering and that people were not
socially distanced while you were there
I thought it was essential for work
purposes November the 13th was a day in
which uh two senior officials in those
senior advisors in government
had left their jobs in very very
difficult and challenging circumstances
and
it was necessary
to steady the ship except that perfect
social distancing sir Bernard is not
being observed but that does not mean
that what we were doing in my view is
incompatible with the guidance I don't
think we agree with your interpretation
of the guidance that
again admitting social distancing not
always followed leading to questions as
to why he didn't correct what he told
MPS I understand the point you make
there is confusion between guidance and
rules but yeah I could have corrected
the record at that point but I I I I I I
didn't think there was any appreciable
difference because it was our job to
follow the guidance as much as to follow
the rules and uh My Views I've as I've
said repeatedly to the committee this
afternoon is that I believe we were
following the guidance
bending instances where he wasn't
socially distanced while also at times
seeking to pass blame onto those around
him if a minister cannot rely on the uh
advice of senior entrusted officials uh
when you have to get a huge amount of
business done okay then it would be
impossible for government to carry on
then the infamous bring your own booze
event an email sent out to staff
inviting them to gather in the garden of
number 10 in May 2020 published evidence
by the committee shows then director of
communications Lee Kane expressing
concern about her 200 odd person
invitation for drinks being somewhat of
a comms risk in the current environment
he was concerned about the Optics not
about the rules and he himself attended
uh the event and certainly no no
concerns will raise with me the event
had been within the rules why were you
concerned about the Optics
I I think I can't say I think he was
concerned about the impression that
people might gain if they looked over uh
the Garden Wall some of the testis
moments came as Boris Johnson was
grilled over his repeated defense that
statements rules weren't breached were
based on assurances by trusted advisors
some might see your Reliance on the
purported assurances you received
as and forgive me as a deflection
mechanism to prevent having to answer
questions about your knowledge of these
gatherings would that not be a fair
assessment no it would be completely
ridiculous assessment you were there at
the time so it's a bit hard to
understand what the nature of an
assurance is when you've been there and
seen it with your own eyes I mean if if
I was going at 100 miles an hour and I
saw the speedometer saying 100 miles an
hour it would be a bit odd wouldn't it
if I said somebody assured me that I
wasn't today a highly uncomfortable
session for this former PM but no
smoking done
both sides stick into their guns the
committee pressing the former prime
minister on what it believed the
evidence pointed to that breaches of
rules and guidance would and should have
been obvious to him while Boris Johnson
insisted it really was not this sent a
standoff between a parliament trying to
assert its Authority in a former prime
minister trying to save his political
career and after hours of evidence the
outcome still very unclear
one thing is clear Mr Johnson will not
accept the findings of this inquiry if
it goes against him sat in the scene for
another party gate Showdown both he and
the current PM could well do without the
standoff but that is beyond their
control Beth Rigby Sky News Westminster